to survive in this high-pressure crazy
world most of us have to become highly
adept at self-criticism we learn how to
tell ourselves off for our failures and
for not working hard or smart enough but
so good are we at this that was
sometimes in danger of falling prey to
an excessive version of self-criticism
what we might call self flagellation a
rather dangerous state which just pushes
in depression and underperformance
we might simply lose the will to get out
of bed for those moments we need a
corrective we need to carve out time for
an emotional state of which many of us
are profoundly suspicious self
compassion
we're suspicious because that sounds
horribly close to self pity but because
depression and self-hatred are serious
enemies of a good life we need to
appreciate the role of self-care in a
good ambitious and fruitful life to this
end we can perform what we've called a
self compassion exercise a structured
meditation lasting 15 minutes or so
lying in bed or perhaps a bath turnover
a sequence of thoughts that interrupt
and correct the flow of your worst self
accusations for a time adopt an entirely
kindly perspective on your setbacks the
self compassion exercise goes like this
me
we're so in love with success we fail to
notice the scale of the challenges we
routinely set ourselves
there is nothing remotely normal about
what we've tried to achieve we failed
but given the mountain we were trying to
climb the conclusion doesn't have to be
that was simply food
we have tricky family histories we all
do there were things which happen to us
at the hands of others which can help to
explain some of our current troubles
we're not entirely sane or well but none
of us are we weren't well set up to
carry out certain tasks it isn't wholly
our fault in the here-and-now
from the media you'd think everyone was
rich and famous and successful but in
reality undramatic quiet failure is by a
huge margin the statistical norm we
shouldn't tear ourselves apart for not
managing to beat what were in truth
awesome
odds tough self-critical people don't
allow themselves the indulgence of
believing in luck they take
responsibility for everything they think
winners make their own luck but they
don't for the most part
luck is a genuine feature of existence
we're robbing ourselves of fair
consolation by believing that we're
entirely in control and therefore
entirely to blame when we craft
scoundrel you are not only your
achievements status and material success
are one bit of you but there are others
as well those who loved you in childhood
knew this and in their best moments
helped you to feel it rehearse the
internalized voices of all those who've
been kind to you bathe in the memory of
a love independent of achievement
it seems it will never end that's not
the truth
it's just how a crisis feels you need to
reduce expectations to zero for a time
take each new hour as it comes and
without being banal what you need most
of all is some rest
you